there is a really really messed up story
in pink news pink news i guess is a gay
website
and so this is a story i guess that's
supposed to be sympathetic to the couple
here it's a gay couple
who wanted a son
sue's ivf clinic after surrogate gives
birth to a daughter
you see this couple these two men
decided that they wanted to purchase a
baby and so they went out and they found
an egg they went through a catalog and
they picked a woman they said okay that
woman that's that's going to be the
mother of my child and they purchased
that woman's eggs and then they rented
the womb of a poor woman and then they
did all sorts of things in
rooms and medical offices and they had
doctors combine the sperm and the egg in
test tubes and then they implanted the
the little babies the embryos into this
other woman
and very often this process involves
abortion uh very often this obviously
this process necessarily uh decouples
the procreative act from the from the
sexual act within marriage which
which just by definition can't exist
here with this gay couple and then they
said okay we want we want our baby to
look like this this this this ooh yucca
girl send him back i want a refund send
her back i want a refund
really really messed up but there are so
many problems here
on the
on the most shallow level it's sexism
this is real they're actually saying i
don't want a girl
to me a girl is less valuable than a boy
i only want a boy send the girl back
that's so there's sexism sure then on
the next level it's the homosexuals well
may you know
that's not how biology works two boys
don't get to make a baby and so when you
try to poke and prod and change
everything and and manipulate nature in
this way bad things are going to happen
yep that's true but that's not even the
deepest level
the real problem here i think
it's the clinic
the real problem is the clinic
and it's not just it's not just the
homosexuals it is the homosexuals but
it's not just the homosexuals it's not
just the sexism it's the clinic it's
it's
ultimately the big problem here is this
mistaken belief that we have a right to
a child
you don't have a right to a child
people struggle with infertility and it
can be so extremely painful sweet little
lisa night we didn't get a baby right
away took took a couple years and i know
i know i know how hard that is i know
it's really truly hard
still you don't have a right to a child
the only person who has any rights when
we are talking about procreation
is the baby and ironically maybe not
ironically
the baby's rights are the rights that we
always discard when we when we talk
about these issues in our society
ironically the only person whose rights
we completely ignore when we're talking
about procreation are the baby's rights
the baby's right to life the baby's
right to his natural mother and father
but the baby is the only person with
rights here babies are not just a
commodity to be purchased on the free
market okay babies are a gift from god
and a baby has
a natural right to his mother and father
a baby has a natural right to be
conceived in the procreative act in the
sexual act the specific conjugal act of
his parents within a marriage okay the
baby has that right
if the baby doesn't have that right
nobody has any rights in this whole
thing okay
but we've we now view babies as
commodities because we have a right to
it and therefore if we have a right to
it we have a right to do whatever we
want to do to be able to get it maybe
that involves technology maybe that
involves gov the government maybe that
involves the free market
if we have a right to a baby this couple
really hasn't done anything wrong
if a baby is a commodity to be purchased
on the free market then look at this
couple they didn't get the product that
they wanted they purchased a product the
the company that produces that product
the company this ivf company didn't give
them the product they want so you have a
right to a refund of course maybe a
30-day money-back guarantee i don't know
the problem here is that a baby is not
just a product just a commodity to be
bought and sold a baby is a human being
made in the image of likeness of god
just like you and the baby has rights
here
this this is a level the concern the
libs
i either don't get this or don't care
they just completely reject that idea
that
babies have rights and and that you
shouldn't be allowed to just force your
will on reality but
the conservatives tend to get this a
little bit more conservatives know that
this is wrong conservatives know this is
deeply deeply wrong but
can are conservatives willing to go all
the way here
are conservatives willing to say well if
you don't have a right to a baby then we
need to have a much more serious
bioethical discussion about all of these
reproductive technologies not just for
the gays not just for single women but
even for married couples maybe we need
to talk a little more seriously about
the bioethical problems with ivf
or i don't know that that a lot of
conservatives want to do that because a
lot of people have used these
technologies and have gotten kids out of
these technologies and so
it's it's easy to ignore the stories
that happen all the time you hear these
stories all the time not just with
homosexuals but you'll hear of a couple
getting the wrong baby oops there was a
mistake with the test tubes and this
couple got this other couple's baby and
now they're lawsuits and
these stories crop up pretty regularly
but if you have personally benefited
from it it's it's easy to ignore those
stories you say oh well it's not a big
deal or oh well it's the cost of doing
business right but babies are not
business they're not they're not
business it's not
we need to place limits here not just on
the government not even on on technology
on the free market you shouldn't be able
to buy and sell people right now go to
ahs.com
knowles do you want peace of mind do you
want to stay on your budget that would
probably be pretty great right now while
prices on everything are going through
the roof well the one thing i promise
you you can expect this year is the
unexpected that's why american home
shield exists as a member you will know
that your budget your time and your
sanity are covered choose a plan from
american home shield keep your budget
goals in check for 2022 they offer a
choice of three great plans to help
cover the cost of repair or replace
parts of major home systems and
appliances no matter their age if
american home shield cannot repair the
covered item they will replace it ahs
members get more more coverage options
fewer exclusions we're talking hvac
systems plumbing kitchen appliances
their plans help protect parts of up to
23 essential home systems and appliances
coverage no matter how old those systems
are keep your home up and running keep
your budget on track with american home
shield right now our listeners can take
50 off their most comprehensive plans
ever go to ahs.com knowles save 50 bucks
that's ahs dot com slash knowles for
fifty dollars off any plan american home
shield be sure with the shield service
fleas limitations and exclusions apply c
plan for details this this goes to an
even deeper level then
it's a way bigger issue and i don't know
that conservatives are totally ready to
open this can of worms the fda just
received its first application for an
over-the-counter birth control pill
this is probably a pretty bad idea by
the way because you know birth control i
mean it's just it just messes with all
of your hormones and as we're living in
a time where all these quacks are
pushing all these sorts of hormonal
treatments i'm not sure that we want to
make it easier
less regulated less oversight when it
comes to showing these drugs
but the application came in
just weeks after the overruling of roe v
wade
and the overruling of roe v wade has
raised questions about contraceptives
so the libs because the libs can't
defend abortion or roe v wade or planned
parenthood be casey the libs focused in
and they said well with this supreme
court decision pretty soon you're going
to lose gay marriage and the right to
homosexual sodomy and contraceptives
because the principle at play in roe v
wade is the principle of play in those
cases and the majority of the court that
overruled roe v wade specifically said
no no this has nothing to do with that
it has nothing to do with condoms or
birth control or anything like that but
justice thomas in his concurrence said
yeah this decision doesn't have to do
with that but probably it should
so thomas gave the really honest answer
here and the court is still right in
practice because well the proof of the
pudding is in the tasting clarence
thomas couldn't get a single other even
conservative judge to sign on to his
concurrence so the court is signaling
they have no appetite to overrule the
quote unquote right to contraception
but there is no right to contraception
in the constitution there is no right to
homosexual sodomy in the constitution
lawrence v texas there is no
definition of gay marriage in the
constitution where did that come no one
even suggested that you could possibly
make that argument until what 2012
2013 or something you might like
contraception
you might like homosexual sodomy you
might like
redefining marriage and you might want
to
pass laws about all those things
but it's not in the constitution it's
just completely made up and it comes
from a
substantive due process which is a an
absurd
pseudo-constitution theory and it comes
from a general right to privacy which
doesn't exist in the constitution and it
comes from all this sort of nonsense all
the same sort of nonsense that you see
in roe v wade
so what what do we say about this as
conservatives
well
if it were me
if it were i know some of the real pro
free market conservatives they'll say
let's get that birth control over the
counter let's do it let's make
everything over the counter let's reduce
regulations that's a very libertarian
point of view
as a conservative i think this is a bad
i think the fda should re should totally
reject this application i think it's a
terrible idea to sell birth control over
the counter i i don't think that our
nation's problem is that we need more
birth control i think the nation's big
problem is we don't have enough babies
america
for the past 50 years has had a below
replacement birth rate the country
is literally dying and now the libs want
to make
hormone birth control pills even easier
to get your hands on without regulation
probably much younger people would be
able to do without parental notification
it's a crazy idea
it's a really bad idea the
in fact the entire birth control regime
is pretty recent it comes from griswold
v connecticut that was a case decided in
1965 which said that married couples
have the right to birth control pills
and condoms and stuff like that and then
a case seven years later eisenstad
versus baird
1972 which says that unmarried couples
have a right to contraceptives as well
so this is very very recent these were
cases decided almost at exactly the same
time as roe v wade with almost the exact
same stupid meanings at almost exactly
the same part where our culture really
began to careen off of the cliff now
what some conservatives will say is well
hold on if you don't want abortion
actually it's mostly liberals who make
this argument they'll say if you don't
want abortion then we need to have
contraception
between the two it's much better to have
contraception than abortion uh okay why
don't we have neither
or why i'm not even saying i'm not
pushing for a nationwide ban on birth
control or something like that
though i do think if people want to ban
birth control they want to go to their
elected representatives and ban it
totally fine by me sounds great
we we need more babies and we have too
much of a culture of contraception
absolutely but
why are those the alternatives what if
we just what if we do
what we did in this country until 1972
and say well you can
either abstain from sex
or you can get married and have kids
and have a good life what if we do that
what people will say then is well in the
modern hookup culture that's just so
unrealistic
where do you think we got the modern
hookup culture from
where do you think that did that just
fall out of the sky
is that is that just politics is
downstream of culture no that's an ep
that's some evidence that culture
frequently is downstream of politics you
get the modern hookup culture
it one sure the these legal decisions
can be influenced by cultural changes
but the legal decisions influence
cultural changes as well and a culture
that enshrines abortion as some right in
a culture that enshrines contraception
of some sacred right and pushes it
everywhere is going to get more of those
things
this is what the libs have been
complaining about after the dobbs
decision you had all these new stories
in the washington post in the new york
times and elsewhere
talking to people who said you know i
think i might start abstaining from sex
i might start being a little more
careful about my sexual partners because
now i can't kill my child so i might
have a baby and and that means i'm gonna
have to be a little more thoughtful
and then the conservatives all said
uh-huh
uh cool sounds great
are the conservatives really willing to
go all the way there are they really
willing to have that conversation
because
very often it feels like what
conservatives want to do is just roll
back the crazy radical cultural changes
about
six years
we just we want to go back to the
halcyon days of
2015 or so i don't
not quite
we do but of course if you if you only
return to the cultural and political
circumstances of the recent past you're
very likely going to end up in exactly
the same place we are now
we have to address root causes why is
our country literally dying
you're going to have to look back at
some changes that took place 50 60 years
ago to figure that out
how did we get to the part the spot
where we're mutilating our little kids
because of political correctness how do
we get to the spot where we're killing
850 000 babies a year how do we get to
the spot where where a homosexual couple
is basically complaining about how they
want to return their baby because they
got a little girl instead of a little
boy at the baby store
we got to go back a little bit further
than just
the past few months or years
i'm so glad you like that clip we are
this close this close
to a million subscribers and i can't
wait to get a million because i know
that's when youtube is gonna nuke my
account i know they're just they're not
gonna let me get that high so let's do
it baby let's accelerate head on over
ring that bell click ding dong like
subscribe whatever you got to do get the
notifications for our new videos we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you